morning all the prime minister may be
thousands of miles away on a trade visit
to india
but he's followed by growing pressure
back home as he's been forced to accept
an investigation by mps into whether or
not he misled parliament over lockdown
breaking parties in downing street so
far a total of 13 of his own mps have
called on the pm to resign the most
recent steve baker he told the comments
yesterday that boris johnson should be
long gone his words also on the list the
former commons chief white mark harper
the former defense minister tobias
elwood and the mp for hazel group
william rag
craig whitaker the mp for calder valley
has said that the prime minister should
do the right thing and resign nigel
mills the mp
for the amber valley and nick gibb
former schools minister both also
withdrawing their support
and both caroline knox mp for ramsey and
southampton north and gary streeter mp
for southwest devon will they have
submitted their letters to the
1922 committee last month andrew
mitchell uh former minister of course
the mp for sutton code field uh well he
first called on the pm to resign back in
january anthony mango magno the mp for
tottenhams ah well he says he's
horrified by the pm's conduct peter
aldis the mp4 waveney and the tory
veteran david davis also among those
calling for a change in leadership uh
let's speak now to our political editor
beth rigby who's traveling with the
prime minister uh on his trip to india
she is in new delhi uh morning beth good
to see you um i watched with interest
your conversation with the prime
minister yesterday i think it's fair to
say he wasn't best pleased
with the direction the interview took
morning neil well the prime minister is
busy this morning
he's been out and about trying to get
this show back on the road meeting with
prime minister modi being greeted at the
presidential palace here in new delhi
but you're quite right
that he wasn't that comfortable
yesterday when he had to do a number of
interviews shortly after the
conservative party decided to drop
attempts to try and delay that vote
into whether
mps can investigate the prime minister
should investigate the prime minister
about what he said in the house of
commons around partygate but he's four
thousands miles away from london but i
can tell you we really did feel the
drama uh here as his trip has been
completely overshadowed by what's
happening back home neil i think today
he'll want to try and get things back on
track as i was saying
there will be a press conference later
with the prime minister he is meeting
prime minister modi now what else might
we want to talk about while these two
gentlemen meet well there's obviously
the trade deal that the prime minister
wants to bang the drum about that's why
he's here he wants to sign a trade deal
with india by the end of this year
yesterday he said he might even get it
as early as autumn the only caveat i
would put on this is he also told us
that there would be a u.s uk trade deal
and that is now being mothballed so
let's see whether this trade deal
happens it certainly seems india's a bit
more enthusiastic
than the us's perhaps to get a deal but
that's the trade element there's also of
course the issue of ukraine now prime
minister modi and prime minister johnson
are pretty close they have a good
relationship but on the issue of ukraine
these men are quite divided prime
minister modi
has been neutral
on the issue of russia's invasion of
ukraine boris johnson has positioned
himself as the west closest ally to
president zielenski but i have to say
unfortunately prime minister modi will
not take questions from the travelling
media with the prime minister today so
we don't get to ask him a question he
will make a statement later about the
visit so keep tuned for all of that
there'll be lots of action here today
but of course we've got eyes on what's
going on at home too
we certainly have beth for now thanks
very much indeed
i'm very pleased to say the northern
ireland minister connor burns joins me
in the studio very good morning to you
and whilst traveling to india the prime
minister has said that he feels that he
has he has nothing to hide
on what basis should we believe him
should we take him at his word given
that the ham-fisted attempts yesterday
in the comments to try and delay this
investigation well look we're going to
have multiple opportunities for the
prime minister's word
to be tested we've got the the met
investigation ongoing we've committed
that once when that's finished sue gray
will complete her report update her
report the primes will come back to
parliament and we've now got the
privileges investigation this is going
to be the most looked at
event possibly since the second world
war why did you try to delay it then i'm
not so sure we did i think there's
something around there well we had we
had a look at the education section
sitting where you are yesterday at this
time saying that was exactly what you
were doing i was in the house on tuesday
afternoon when the prime minister was
asked this question directly what did he
want the house to do and he said it's
for the house to decide i think that was
in response to
stella crecy and that's what we got to i
think i think where the confusion was is
that was there was a concern
that the house investigation the
privileges committee would begin an
investigation and inquiry while the met
investigation was ongoing and before the
su grey
report was finally published i think
that confusion was cleared up and it
became clear that they would not
commence that until the met was finished
and the grey report was published so
there was there wasn't an amendment
table there wasn't an amendment pulled
minutes before the vote that well the
president i missed that well the prime
minister has been very clear that
the house can look at this the house
will look at this and he is confident
that when the full context one of the
other things he said in the house on
tuesday he was frustrated that he
couldn't speak about the context of all
of this put the full facts into the
public domain while these various
processes are ongoing particularly the
met sure he remains confident that when
everyone when people can see the full
context of what happened it will be
clear that he was straightforward he
said to the house in good faith that he
believed the rules were followed people
might take you at face value but not for
the fact that we have been here before
in precisely the same situation this is
owen patterson volume 2. the
conservative party tries to play games
with your partner with asking me with
parliamentary procedure it's clear that
you don't have the support on your own
back benches to go through with it you
pull it you've got egg in your face it's
another crunching gear change another
embarrassing u-turn well i don't accept
that there's any parallel to the
patterson situation that was a situation
where the standards committee had looked
at something it had come to a conclusion
it had made a recommendation and the
house rebelled and chemicals
i'm just accepting that the house
rebelled an attempt to change that i
think people concede in retrospect that
was a mistake this is a was around how
the
the sorry the privileges committee could
look at all of the events around the
events in downing street and i think the
question the only question was around
timing and as i said the prime minister
said on tuesday it'll be for the house
to decide the prime minister said from
india he has nothing to fear nothing to
hide he looks forward to that process he
looks forward to the full facts and
crucially the context coming out i'm
sure he's looking forward to it because
he's looking forward to this ending i
think he's looking forward to drawing
this to a conclusion for it to be
examined fully so that we can move on to
the things that people are genuinely
concerned about in terms of cost of
living energy price rises all those
other things the situation going on in
ukraine the things that that are in man
towards the government probably the most
challenging set of circumstances facing
a government in peacetime but but let's
be absolutely clear in in letting
yesterday's motion essentially go
through on the node the government has
basically admitted this assertions the
prime minister has made on the floor of
the house about the legality of
activities number 10 and the cabinet
office appear to amount to misleading
the house i mean i'm old enough to
remember when cabinet ministers would
step down for inadvertently misleading
the house amber rudd did so why is there
any question right now of whether of the
prime minister going well there's no
question of the prime minister going not
going i shouldn't say the question is
how do we complete this process how do
we get the facts into the public domain
how are they fully examined and how can
the prime minister then speak very
candidly about the context in which
events happen
can we just finish this on the motion
because this is very important that was
an opposition day motion opposition
motions happen all the time they're
frequently not voted on the motion
intended to get the events the the
events surrounding what happened in
downing street in front
of the committee that has happened
that's the consequence what the motion
said was really nearly there now there
this house believes that the prime
minister's conduct appears to amount to
misleading the house as i said
for for less than what the prime
minister has done i mean genuinely i
think we are now at the point where we
have to ask the question under what
circumstances would this prime minister
resign what would it take for him to
leave downing street when beth rigby
asked him about this on the plane on the
way out to india his response is pretty
dramatic not a lot springs to mind well
the prime minister i look i was at the
event in downing street the the
statement on tuesday i went to the 22
committee and i listened to the prime
minister explain to the parliamentary
party what the unfinished business of
his government is and what he wants to
deliver for the british people i walked
out with him totally coincidentally he
wasn't talking to me about parties or
inquiries or metropolitan police
investigations he wanted to talk to me
about what was going on in northern
ireland he wanted to talk about the
business of government take for this
prime minister to resign we know that he
won't resign when you know the police
essentially at point out that he has
broken the law inside downing street he
won't resign when senior members of his
cabinet break the law by attending
parties in downing street he won't
resign when the supreme court rules that
he has acted unlawfully in proroguing
parliament and he has misled the queen
we already know of course because it's
being talked about in the papers as well
you're already preparing to to break
international law again by
tearing up the nardin protocol so again
i asked let's just forgive me how are we
preparing to break in tonight
the reports this morning are that we're
getting to the point now in terms of the
northern ireland protocol that we're
going back to the drawing board that you
will pass legislation that will
essentially allow you to tear it up but
the question i've asked no no this is
very important because you just said
that the government is preparing to tear
up international law regarding uh the
the the you did predict
you've just been sorry you've just put
to me as a northern minister that we're
preparing to break international law on
the northern iron protocol if you are
talking about the long-standing
assertion going back as far as july last
year that we believe that the
circumstances the threshold for
triggering article 16 a provision of the
treaty of the protocol a provision of
the very protocol invoking that
provision that's not breaking
international law that is applying a
trigger mechanism that is built into the
project brandon lewis in the house of
commons not that long ago suggesting
that you would break international law
again i'll repeat the point domestic law
he has broken constitutional law he has
broken international law he has broken
at what point do we have to ask whether
or not this prime minister has
that you have a rule of law you have
asserted that the prime minister has
misled parliament i do not accept that i
believe that the prime minister when he
said to the house of cons at each stage
what he said he believed on the advice
that he was receiving that what he told
in good faith the house of commons was
correct do you think and when it has
emerged
the primary question so the president
the prime minister the prime minister
and the chance of this check have both
received fixed penalty notices for that
event in the cabinet room in number 10.
both of them have accepted the fixed
penalty notice and both of them have
paid it the prime minister said to the
house on tuesday except that you don't
believe that
he said on tuesday that it did not occur
to him then or subsequently that that
gathering that meeting which was to
discuss very important matters in
relation to the government's the united
kingdom's response to covert was in any
way a breach of the rules however he has
said he accepts the decision that the
metropolitan police had come to which is
a different conclusion and he has paid
one of which answers the question do you
think that the prime minister broke the
law or do you still maintain that he was
ambushed by a cake well i was trying to
make a point and it's not often you get
to write a line in your obituary live on
national television i was trying to make
a point the prime minister had been
outside london he'd visited a school i
think he did eight or ten meetings in
downing street that morning before going
to harfordshire to visit the school he
had returned to start another meeting to
which the chancellor came to the cabinet
room to attend and in between that there
was a spontaneous gathering to wish him
a happy birthday
he was conducting the business of
government
in a sense now that is all
irrelevant he has accepted the decision
of the police he has paid the fine and
he is now accepting all the inquiries
into this so that the full facts can be
established he has committed that when
the great report some sort of fringe
opinion that it's some kind of niche
view that boris johnson has misled the
house 80 percent of the british public
thinks he's lying
well i do not believe the prime minister
has lied and i believe that when the
full facts are seen when the context
comes out that it will be clear that the
prime minister every time that he came
to parliament was faithful and genuine
and true in what he believed 61 percent
tory voters in 2019 do not believe him
what i believe is the prime minister
told the house what he believed to be
the truth in good faith at each stage
and when there has been a development
subsequent subsequent to that new
information he has corrected the record
the other important thing and this is
this is important he has accepted that
the number 10 operation was not working
as it should have done he has
fundamentally restructured his operation
in number 10 to make it much more
transparent and accountable he's brought
in steve barkley as chief of staff david
canzini a formidable political operative
as deputy chief of staff he's got new
parliamentary private secretaries the
operation is now much more streamlined
and effective to serve the prime
minister and the government's agenda how
many more fixed penalty notices can
boris johnson receive without
resigning i mean channel 4's gary gibbon
put the point to the pm yesterday you
look at downing street you look at the
number of fines that have been issued
i'm not sure there's a workplace in the
entire country that has had more fpns
handed out the downing street so how
many is too many
i think look it would be completely
wrong for me as a serving government
minister to try and influence or comment
on a live a police investigation the
police must get on with it i think
they've now gone quiet until after the
local elections although their work will
carry on let's get all the information
out there we want it out there as
quickly as possible because the prime
minister wants to get on with the
business of delivering for the british
people on that amazing majority that he
won just over two years ago the stuff
going on in ukraine watching the prime
minister marshalling the international
community's response to the events of
president putin's incursion invasion
into ukraine seeing the prime minister
representing britain walking around the
streets of downtown kiev with president
zielinski these are the things the prime
minister wants to get on with and i
think those are really the things the
british people ultimately want to see us
get on with too many great to have in
the studio thank you very much
uh shall we have a quick look at the
papers uh here's the metro it declares
the gig's up boris mr johnson now facing
a parliamentary inquiry into partygate
growing calls of course uh from his own
mps to resign as well
picturing the prime minister on his trip
to india the telegraph describes him as
buckling to pressure for an
investigation
uh here's the eye it proclaims tori
rebels force official inquiry into
johnson
the guardian refers uh to today it
refers to yesterday i should say as a
day of humiliation for boris johnson
meanwhile in other news according to the
ft there could be another route over
brexit as the government may introduce
legislation that effectively rips up the
northern ireland trade protocols as we
were just discussing with mr burns
now the sun
has a picture of the footballer
cristiano ronaldo with his family after
he and his partner georgina rodriguez
lost their newborn son very sad
and the daily express reports that
british scientists are on the verge of a
revolutionary new cancer treatment
thanks to breakthroughs in finding
genetic clues to the disease
stay right where you are plenty coming
up on the show this morning
and with ukrainian forces continuing to
hold out in mario paul we'll get the
latest on what it means for the war with
the ukrainian mp
then as the pressure mounts on mps over
sorry on the pm over the partygate
scandal i'll speak with conservative
peer and former chief of staff to
theresa may lord
[Music]
just after eight we'll get all the
reaction to this morning's latest
developments with the shadow northern
ireland secretary peter kyle
this could be significant police in
portugal have identified a german man as
a formal suspect in their investigation
into the disappearance of madeleine
mccann in 2007. the man known as
christian b
is currently in prison in germany
serving a conviction for raping a woman
in the same area of portugal's algarve
reason where a region where madeleine
went missing the british girl was just
three years old when she was went
missing from a holiday apartment in
prague de luz nearly 15 years ago
so guys katie barnfield is outside
scotland yard for us this morning good
to see you katie just explain the
significance of this individual being
named please
good morning neil well this 44 year old
individual known as christian b because
of strict
privacy laws in germany was identified
as a suspect by german authorities in
2020 but he was never charged now as you
say he has now been named as what's
known as a formal suspect by portuguese
authorities and the reason this is
important is that it could allow him to
be transferred from germany where he is
currently serving a prison sentence to
the algarve for formal questioning
by authorities there now investigators
clearly believe that he killed madeleine
after abducting her when she was age
three
from a holiday from a holiday apartment
in prior de las uh in 2007 and there are
suggestions that this move is being made
now because under portuguese law there
is a time limit effectively by which a
person can be declared a person of
interest and if a crime could carry the
maximum sentence the time limit is 15
years so that means the latest time that
they could actually declare someone as a
person of interest would be
may the third although the portuguese
authorities deny this and say that it is
because of strong criminal
investigations that it's criminal
evidence that this christian bee
was involved now he is already serving a
sentence in germany for the rape of a 72
year old woman also in prior delusion in
2005 and this is the first time that a
formal suspect has actually been
named in the investigation into
madeleine mccann's disappearance since
her own parents were charged and then
later
cleared now the metropolitan police is
still treating this as a missing
person's inquiry although there have
been uh of course enormous interest in
madeleine's disappearance she has never
been uh has never since been found but
they say that any further investigations
uh are matter for the portuguese
authorities
katie thanks very much indeed
now the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has claimed that russia has
rejected a proposal for a truce over
orthodox easter this weekend the u.n
secretary general had proposed a
four-day humanitarian pause to the
fighting during the period but no such
truce came leaving the besieged city of
mario paul in an ever more desperate
state
the southern port city has been a key
strategic target for the russian
federation since the war began capturing
it while it would help create a land
bridge between russia
and occupied crimea
russia now controls almost all of the
city
but for the azov style steelworks where
an estimated 2 000 ukrainian fighters
are still holed up
vladimir putin's decision not to storm
the plant will come as little comfort to
those still trapped in mario paul after
the city council said as many as 9 000
civilians could be buried in mass graves
outside the besieged city
uh speak now to our security and defence
editor deborah haynes joining us now i'm
from the ukrainian capital good to see
you deborah reports of mass graves
ceasefires
not taken this this conflict continues
to be very very bloody indeed
yes really grim uh reports about the
potential for more mass graves there's
been some new satellite imagery released
by a u.s
satellite company which seems to show
the digging of a of masquerade of a mass
grave in a village just outside mariupol
and yes like you said the mayor of the
city uh believing that russia is trying
to hide its crimes picking up bodies
from the street and then dumping them in
these mass graves we've seen mass graves
outside of kiev during the time that
russian forces were in control of towns
and villages there so you can only
imagine what might be happening in mario
paul i spoke to the mayor actually a few
days ago and he said that anything that
happened in places like butcher
times that by 10 and that's what you've
got in mario pole a city that has been
at the heart of the heaviest fighting
over the longest period and like you say
there is still this steel works in the
city where ukrainian fighters are
holding out where there are there are
hundreds of wounded fighters as well
unable to get medical attention and also
civilians believed to be in that steel
works you can only imagine how horrific
it must be for them and the uk's defense
ministry has in its daily tweets that it
puts out on the situation uh with
regards to the war made this very
interesting observation about vladimir
putin's decision yesterday
not to send his forces into the other
style steel works to clear out the
ukrainian resistance the uk saying that
this is likely because of a desire to
keep blockading the resistance to
contain it and then free up russian
forces to be able to fight elsewhere in
the east remember this is the second
phase now of the war a western official
yesterday said it's still possible for
putin to win this war but to do that
he's clearly going to need more forces
concentrated elsewhere in the country
deborah many thanks
now let's take a quick look at some of
the day's other headlines now and a
survey has found more than half of
people say the surging cost of living is
holding them back from saving as they
want to
workplace pension and savings provider
cushion says that two-fifths believe
that april's national insurance hike to
help pay for health and social care will
make their situation worse
as the earl and contest of wessex
prepare to set off for a platinum
jubilee tour of the caribbean they've
been set a hard-hitting letter accusing
the royal family of profiting from
slavery and demanding reparations at the
last minute the grenada leg of the visit
has been called off now the letter from
the antigua and barbuda reparations
commission threatens to overshadow the
tour
let's take a look at the letter it says
this we know that the british crown both
as royal family and as institution is
historically documented as an active
participant in the largest crimes
against humanity of all time
we know however that everyone in your
family continues to live in the splendor
pomp and wealth attained through the
proceeds of the crimes
hundreds of offences have been reported
at royal palaces in the last three years
including crimes involving weapons drugs
violence and robbery the metropolitan
police said a total of 470 offences were
recorded buckingham palace kensington
palace st james's palace and clan's
house either inside or immediately
outside between 2019 and 2021.
the crimes included hundreds of thefts
along with reports of arson criminal
damage burglary robbery and possession
of weapons
it is the last day of campaigning in
france's presidential election before
voters cast their ballots in the runoff
between emmanuel macro and his far-right
opponent marine le pen our international
affairs editor dominic wiacon has the
latest
marine le pen told me yesterday she
thought she still had a good chance of
winning this election these are volatile
unpredictable times that have favored
disruptive candidates in other parts of
the world and have confounded opinion
polls but it has to be said that in
france pollsters tend to be more
accurate than many and barring a
last-minute upset she is unlikely to
close the at least 12-point gap that
seems to be between her and manny macron
still in the opinion polls it was
telling that yesterday they were out in
different kinds of areas she was
campaigning in a safe area for her in
northern france taking no risks
talking to truckers not far from here in
aras and her rival emmanuel macron was
going out to more dangerous turf to
sandonee north of paris a multi-ethnic
poorer community both of those
candidates are fighting over the 22
percent of voters who voted for jean-luc
meloncho in the first round of this
election a far-left candidate and it
looks as though macron's tactics of
reaching out to those voters is paying
off opinion polls look like he's going
to get far more of those votes
than marine le pen is likely to
she is doing what she can to to close
the gap and find momentum but it looks
like on the last day of campaigning her
wheels are spinning she's failing to get
that traction she needs to catch up with
the manny macron so barring any
last-minute surprise it looks like he's
more and more assured of victory
dominique wyckon there now johnny depp
has spent an uncomfortable third day in
the witness box been cross-examined by
his ex-wife's lawyer he was asked about
texts he sent to other celebrities about
amber heard and about his aggressive
behavior as david blevins reports
for three consecutive days johnny depp
has been in the witness box becoming
animated at times alleging the tip of
his finger was severed when amber haired
through a bottle
but the mood in the courtroom changed
when his ex-wife's lawyers
cross-examined him showing a video she'd
secretly recorded of the actor banging
covered doors in his west hollywood home
[Music]
i did not uh
try to intimidate miss heard if she was
intimidated
why was she filming if she was scared to
death why didn't she leave
earlier jurors had been shown a picture
of bags of marijuana in his recording
studio
and several pictures of words he'd
written in his own blood after the
finger injury
johnny depp was asked about text
messages he'd sent to the actor paul
bettany one reading let's burn amber
another let's join her before we burn
her avoid text messages to marilyn
manson discussing drug taking and about
his relationship with elton john from
whom he sought help when trying to get
sober
beyond the trial his representatives
issued a statement explaining that
burning and drowning were references to
a scene in the monty python film
implying they'd been taken out of
context
[Applause]
depp's suing heard for 50 million
dollars over an article she wrote about
domestic violence
and she's countersuing him for 100
million dollars the trial scheduled to
run for another three weeks
david blevins sky news virginia in the
last half an hour the northern ireland
minister conor burns has told me he
doesn't believe the prime minister has
lied about the events surrounding
partygate
i do not believe the prime minister has
lied and i believe that when the full
facts are seen when the context comes
out that it will be clear that the prime
minister every time that he came to
parliament was faithful and genuine and
true in what he believed 61 percent
tory voters in 2019 do not believe him
what i believe is the prime minister
told the house what he believed to be
the truth in good faith at each stage
and when there has been a development
subsequent subsequent to that new
information he has corrected the record
and rob powell joins us in the studio
good to see you this morning and what
did we make of what we heard from conor
burns
he's widely known in westminster to be a
fairly close eyeliner of the prime
minister yeah i was about to say the
first thing to set out is that conor
burns is someone that's been quite close
to boris johnson for a long time so what
you are hearing now is essentially the
sort of operation save big dog defense
if you like and i think around this
question of whether the prime minister
lied in the commons which of course is
important because if you're found to
have knowingly misled the house of
commons no then that is widely accepted
and has been admitted as such by cabinet
ministers to be a resignation
instance
you are hearing the defense which is
essentially that
at the time
it wasn't he may have misled the house
but it wasn't deliberate because he
believed at the time that what he was
saying about attending birthday parties
and things like that um we didn't
believe that was a rule break at the
time so it wasn't deliberate the
difficulty with that excuse though is if
more fines come out for more egregious
breaches and then if we get the full su
grey report that investigation by the
senior civil servant that sort of adds
more flesh to the bones of these fines
and does can find more compelling
evidence that the prime minister did
know what he was doing that sort of
defensive of kind of ignorance at the
time may not wash and may only weaken
his position with his own mps further
rob for many thanks indeed
let's stick with the story show we can
get a little bit more reaction to the
pressure mounting on the prime minister
very pleased to save and speak now uh to
gavin barwell lord batword conservative
peer and what formerly theresa may
dining street chief of staff between
2017 and 2019. gavin great to see you
this morning i have been at this week
rereading your book about your time in
number 10. i wonder from your
perspective as a as someone who used to
run things behind the scene what you
make of what we're witnessing in and
around whitehall at the moment
it's pretty unprecedented i think in in
two ways
the first is that normally when a
government gets into trouble it's
because it's doing something that is
either very unpopular with your viewers
or it's doing something that is
unpopular internally with its party
whereas the problems the current
government have got are all about the
prime minister's behavior essentially
they're not about policy uh issue
and then i think the second way in which
it's unprecedented is
both you know i as a former politician
and you as a journalist i think we would
probably agree
that whenever a government has a
difficult story the best way to handle
it is to get all the facts out there as
quickly as possible and and be contrite
whereas
the handling of this story has said the
truth has been dragged out of number 10
day by painful day over about six months
yeah
just in terms of of what we saw clearly
in terms of the strategy the government
is suffering on the big picture stuff
you know
there is a degree of truth to the fact
that actually there is an awful lot for
the government to be doing right now and
there is an awful lot of focus on
everything else but just look at the way
in which the amendment and the motion
yesterday this
once again the conservative government
doesn't appear to to know the mood of
its own back benches
yeah i think yesterday was it was a
hugely significant day in two regards
the first as you say
is that the whips clearly believed they
could get the conservative mps to vote
for this amendment and discover that
they couldn't so that tells us that the
mood among conservative mps isn't quite
as supportive of the pm as maybe uh some
people were having us believe two or
three days ago and secondly i think
steve baker's intervention yesterday
is very significant you know steve was a
key person uh in terms of teresa's
downfall
he likes not someone i agree with
ideologically but he is a highly
principled person and he's also
a very effective operator so if i was
still doing my old job in number 10 i
would be very worried about that
intervention yesterday
so just in terms of the mood within the
kind of conservative parliamentary party
at the moment i mean do you detect from
the conversations that you will i'm sure
be having uh with colleagues said you're
in the comments do you detect the death
rattle for boris johnson's time as prime
minister i mean on so many occasions up
until now people have predicted his
demise and he has
and he has stayed firmly put
i don't think we're there yet
i think what i would say is that there
is severe discomfort at what the prime
minister has done and mp's having to
defend it
the thing that is the two things that i
think are keeping him in place at the
moment if this had happened
two or three months ago before the
conflict in ukraine
and before the problems that rishi
sunaka's got into then i think
definitely that would have been the end
so that the two things that are
allowing people like connor to to mount
a defense of the prime minister are
don't change right now given what's
going on in the world
and the lack of a clear obvious
alternative that mps could switch to but
you know i think this story's got a way
to play yet with i suspect the prime
minister is going to receive more fines
because actually the birthday party
event was probably the least egregious
of the breaches that we've read about
we're going to get the sue grey report
now we've got this privileges committee
investigation so
and my own view has been very clear for
a while that the prime minister should
go on because i think what he's done is
indefensible and i don't think it's in
the interest of the conservative party
for him to stay
but not all mps are at that point yet i
suspect this has got a way to go still
how concerned then should the party's
strategist be
about the may local elections i mean i
saw some speculation this morning could
be as high as 800 seats lost
across the board but you always have to
bear in mind the conservatives have been
in government since 2010
the government tends to lose seats with
local elections i mean it's possible
they can spin their way out of this one
yes i think it depends how bad the
results turn out to be you you would exp
you know let's be honest
we've got a we've got a cost of living
crisis going on at the moment which is
not
uh ultimately caused by the government
it's a it's a global economic situation
that every advanced economy is facing
but understandably voters are concerned
and angry about that and feeling that
the government hasn't done enough to
support them
uh and then you've got this party gay
issue on top of that so
the the thing that conservative mps will
be looking at afterwards is how bad were
the results
relative to previous years to try and
get a gauge of how strongly
uh the public feel about uh this issue
and that could be another trigger point
as could be the wakefield by-election
that we've got coming up
at some point in the near future
just to conclude
in all seriousness what what do you
think of boris johnson as an individual
and as a prime minister i've read your
books i've got a rough idea
so
i i have a slightly schizophrenic view
of him i think he has some real
qualities i think if you take
ukraine he's handled that issue exactly
as i would have wanted my prime minister
to do it
but i'm afraid in other regards he falls
short of what i think we all have to
right to respect to expect in terms of
our prime minister and in this
particular story it's not just what he
did
at a time when all of the rest of us
were bringing he passed laws
severely restricting all of our freedoms
and then didn't obey them himself but
it's the way he's behaved since those
allegations first came to like the way
the truth has been dragged out of him so
my my own view is very clear that they
can that we
he's failed if you like to pass the test
of acceptable behavior for a prime
minister and he needs to go
uh but ultimately this is a decision
that can serve to mps uh only they have
got a say in this until the next
election
uh so
there are definitely some things he's
done that he can be proud of and i think
most people in this country would
support but in several critical regards
he falls short of what we have a right
to respect in terms of uh prime minister
gavin baldwin great to have you on the
program this morning appreciate your
time
pleasure
lewis hamilton and serena williams are
committing millions of pounds to one of
the bids for chelsea fc sky news
understands both are backing the
takeover offer for the club being
spearheaded by sir martin broughton the
former liverpool and british airways
chairman roman abramovich put the club
up for sale after 19 years of ownership
our city editor mark clyman looks at the
runners and writers
it's the three billion pound question
gripping english football which group of
billionaire financiers sports team
owners and celebrities will get their
hands on chelsea fc
the latest suitors as revealed by sky
news serena williams winner of 23 grand
slam tennis titles and so lewis hamilton
the seven times formula one world
champion
the sale of last season's champions
league winners triggered by the
sanctioning of owner roman abramovich
kicked off only seven weeks ago but it's
already nearing the final whistle
the likelihood is that this is going to
run a little bit like the premier league
both top and bottom of the table is
going to run towards the end of the
season the due diligence process
in any football club
these days is is a very is a very
tortuous one even when you're buying a
trophy asset
the uncertainty surrounding the blues
future has not deterred some of the
biggest names in finance media and sport
from trying to buy one of european
football's trophy assets
which means that chelsea's sale is
likely to become the most lucrative club
takeover in history
as well as its pair of sporting
superstars the bid led by sir martin
broughton includes backing from josh
harris and dave blitzer two american
billionaires who own basketballs
philadelphia 76ers and the new jersey
devils ice hockey team
another of the offers is led by steve
palyuca a shareholder in the boston
celtics basketball side and larry
tannenbaum the nba chairman their
backers include the former disney chief
bob iger
the other consortium is led by the la
dodger's part owner todd bowley and
includes funding from clear lake capital
a us-based investment firm
it was here a year ago that a fans
revolt against the european super league
caused it to be abandoned the backlash
will mean an independent football
regulator and tougher rules governing
who can own professional clubs but it's
also thrown a renewed spotlight on the
future earning power of clubs like this
and chelsea's next owners are unlikely
to be as generous as mr abramovic
a preferred bidder could be picked next
week with the sale taking place next
month after 19 major trophies in as many
years under mr abramovic there's no
guarantee that whoever replaces him will
bring a similar record of success
mark kleinman sky news
cristiano ronaldo has shared a
photograph of his newborn daughter
arriving home following the loss of her
twin
the manchester united striker posted the
family picture on his instagram page
saying now is the time to be grateful
for the life he and his partner georgina
rodriguez had welcomed into the world he
added both of them felt all the love
they'd been given since their baby son
died
yeah let's get you a little bit more now
on the race for the french presidency
and take a closer look at how both
emmanuel macron and marine le pen have
set out their stalls over the course of
the campaign
very pleased to say the author sophie
perr joins us now from paris sophie
lovely to see you this morning um i
wonder if we might start uh with the
debate that took place uh between le pen
and macron my french isn't what it once
was so i'm hoping yours is rather better
how did you how did you rate the
candidates
well it was a much more constructive
debate in some ways than when they met
each other five years ago and that was
when marine le pen really was very
aggressive and ended up being sort of
crushed i suppose by macron during the
debate this time she held her own she
was much more poised it was emmanuel
macron in some respects who was more
aggressive going after her especially
over her
links to russia and to vladimir putin
and she i think looked a little bit more
wobbly on some of the policy issues that
have actually been right at the front of
her campaign like cost of living how she
would um cut the 80 on fuel and food
prices which are popular but you know
raised questions about financing and
that's when emmanuel macron really sort
of went for her but uh you know i think
at the end of the day that debate isn't
going to change minds because people who
don't like macron will have found him
condescending and uh slightly sort of
patronizing in his sort of body language
and those who don't like marine le pen
would have found her you know as
incompetent as they probably thought she
was beforehand if not dangerous
what then of the of the likely outcome
of all of this i mean emmanuel macron is
not a very popular man when you look at
when you look at the opinion polls
approval rating between negative 11
negative 31
last year and yet
as things stand he is predicted to win
and win by a margin
i know it's amazing really isn't it
because uh he isn't loved i think he's
respected by some people but people find
it difficult to relate to him he's got a
pretty track record you know france has
actually brought down unemployment while
he's been in office which used to be the
big curse of the french economy and
that's already something of an
achievement he hasn't done a bad job
during the pandemic um and you know his
diplomatic efforts over ukraine and
russia have been not successful but
they've been at least sort of applauded
i suppose by the french but he isn't
like to something about his manner
there's something about uh the way
people see him as disconnected from the
people and that's very much what marie
lapine has been playing on she likes to
represent herself as you know the voice
of the people um when the people vote
the people win is one of her campaign
slogans so you know i think that this is
a divided country and i think that even
if emmanuel macron does win which is
what the polls suggesting on sunday he
will inherit or take over continue to
run
a country that is that is really
fractured and that is going to be a big
challenge for him when he uh if and when
he he starts his second term
but how concerned should we be that
despite the fact she has rebranded
herself marine le pen is polling about
40 and she is a politician of the far
right by the standards that we have here
in this country how concerned should we
be about that
i think it is a worry i mean france has
become more polarized you know what's
happened i suppose under emmanuel macron
is that he's created this huge centrist
party uh and really sort of occupied a
vast space which has taken in both the
sort of moderate left and the moderate
right uh and crushed those traditional
parties that used to dominate french
politics the socialists and the
republicans and in doing so he's in a
sense you know the the main opposition
to him has become the extremes so you've
had radical populist candidates on both
the far left and the far right that have
um emerged now it's when it comes to
i'm so sorry we are literally 20 seconds
away from the break so we're gonna have
to leave it there sophie pedder author
of revolution frances thank you very
much for joining us